welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back
[Music]
release Back In 1980 this changed the
movie industry for the several decades
that followed it it's almost become a
catchphrase to describe the darkest
chapter in a franchise it's being its
quote-unquote Empire Strikes Back and
there's a lot going on with this movie
that's made its Legacy so impactful
[Music]
but what makes it so special and why is
it got such a big Legacy well throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
all down and going over the making of
its Easter eggs and the Thematic
elements that make it a masterpiece
subscribe you will and Thumbs Up Button
hit for videos like this every single
week without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into The
Empire Strikes Back The Empire Strikes
Back
now A New Hope Came as a massive
surprise to everyone most notably George
Lucas expecting it to be a bomb he
didn't even go to the premiere and in
steady vacation with Steven Spielberg
whilst the movie was being shown whilst
the power away though they came up with
the idea for Indiana Jones and George
felt like this next project might save
his reputation hi there as we know Star
Wars was an incredible phenomenon and
after it blew up the box office
it also achieved a best picture
nomination Star Wars earn more money
than any other movie had ever made in
history and this sequel was quickly put
into production now if you checked out
our last video then you'll know how
stressed out Lucas was when he was
making that first film that is severe
impact on his health and he knew that
the sequel was gonna have to be bigger
and better if he made the movie he'd
have to work out the finances run the
production company and also be there
every day directing it this would
undoubtedly lead to a much bigger toll
unless he decided to put things in place
to take a step back whilst overseeing
the production Lucas actually tied with
selling the rights to the sequels off to
20th Century Fox but in the end he felt
like it couldn't be entrusted with
others which moving on are you seeing
the 12 million he made from a new hope
he decided to put that money into his
production company ilm and he also set
up Skywalker Movie Ranch out in
California taking out a bank loan he
also self-financed the film and went for
a budget of 25 million dollars which was
double the first movie written by Hurley
from lost Lucas worked away in his Ranch
on the screenplay whilst concept art was
created for completely alien locations
that were the opposite of the first film
Lucas wanted to do more than just rehash
that movie so he had Luke training as a
Jedi and also a romance between Han and
Leia now Lucas originally offered the
director's job to David Lynch but he
turned it down due to his surrealist
style not matching with Lucas's Vision
Lynch later went on to make 1984's tune
which though I enjoy was a pretty major
flop now taking his old teacher Irving
kirschner to learn she pitched in the
idea but this was initially turned down
and I said she George
I don't think so Kirshner was someone
who was known for small character-driven
indie films but this is why he felt that
he'd be perfect for the role convinced
by his age and he then got to work and
the crew created 60 sets which vastly
outweighed the first film I love this
movie it was gonna be big and bombastic
it was very much a character piece that
would see the heroes at the lowest
points now to me this has always been
the appeal of Empire and Lucas went
through numerous idea changes when
putting it all together he wanted to
include the emperor in a big bad way but
he also had to explain how Mark Hamill
had suffered facial injuries Hamill
actually got into a very serious car
accident just after filming the first
movie and this actually left Lucas
unable to reshoot parts of it Lucas had
apparently told them that had he died
then they would ever cast him and then
Focus his story on Luke's long-lost
sister you can kind of see how that
would play into the future and Hamill
apparently got told at one point that
his sister was in fact layer now they
ended up explaining the slight change in
hamel's appearance through the one
parent attack as the surgery adjusted
his face a bit from how it looked in the
first film he got a fractured nose and
also a cheekbone but to be honest I
never really noticed the difference and
yeah let me know if if you picked up on
it I'm sure you've heard the rumors
though about them purposely shooting
that scene to explain the scars but at
the time most of them had healed up that
whole story is a bit of bantapuru and
the scene would have been in the film
anyway as I needed a way to have Obi-Wan
return to tell him to go to dagapot and
these scenes were all shot without them
actually knowing if Alec Guinness would
return and had he not then they would
have been completely
hello there now Lucas actually hired
science fiction writer Elite bracket to
help punch up the dialogue and they
worked away and came up with the core
ideas firstly that'd be something on The
Wookie Homeworld the emperor a gambler
from Han's past a frog-like creature and
someone called minshota the name Yoda
was taken from the Sanskrit word yodha
which translates to English to mean
warrior now after some changes there was
a city in the cloud added the snow
Planet Hearth and a Chase through an
asteroid belt there's also a battle
between Luke and Vader and originally
they wanted the ghost of Anakin to visit
his son and be accompanied by Obi-Wan
now this is where stuff starts to differ
and it was from here that things
diverted off completely Han was gonna go
on to recruit his powerful stepfather
and Lando was going to be revealed to be
a clone from the Clone Wars Lucas made
notes and tried to reach out to bracket
but she sadly was hospitalized and died
of cancer just a few weeks later now
because of this Lucas's hands were tied
and after bringing Lawrence kazden on
they then reworked the script actually
enjoy showing the process this time
Lucas made changes based off her work
but in the end he struggled to close out
the third act instead he flirted with
the idea of dropping invader's castle
and his fear of the emperor which gets
brought across the main film beta's big
thing is of course trying to get his son
to join him and he very much gives away
that they can rule a Galaxy together
that would be without the emperor and
there was plans in place that the pair
would join up and then fight him
together join me and together we can the
Galaxy is Father and Son now bounty
hunters were also brought in to track
down Luke and at this point they started
conceptualizing Boba Fett he was gonna
be based on the man with no name and
this is actually why the Sands of Spurs
are used when he's on screen introduced
in the Star Wars holiday special there
were also plans at one point to give him
an all-white costume Lucas testing this
out can be seen in certain images with
the idea being that he could be named
the super Stormtrooper he also bring
across the scalp of a Wookie which
Jeremy Bullock kept rushing out the way
because he thought it was a dislodged
hairpiece this is all discussed in his
autobiography flying solo not lying
where he talked about how he also played
an imperial in the movie who dragged
Slayer out the way the actor who was
supposed to play him didn't end up
showing up and thus Bullock stepped out
of the costume to play this minor pot
imagine right all the bragging rights in
the work that guy could have got off the
back of being an Empire and he literally
had one job and couldn't even do that
[Music]
a fat does appear in the special edition
of a new Hub when Han meets Jabba but
it's important to bear in mind that was
added in with CGI and brackets draft she
also had Obi-Wan telling like to leave
his training whereas lucasfelder gave
Luke more agency to decide to do it
himself the scene in the cave with a
vision of Vader was also reworked too
and originally Luke's flirting with the
dark side was shown completely
differently Luke was going to Wally
Massacre Stormtroopers which somewhat
got reused down the line when Anakin
murdered the Tuscan Raiders I killed
them
I killed them all and not just the men
but the women
and the children too I may come come
down calm down I hate them a titling it
The Empire Strikes Back Minch Yoda was
reworked too well he guessed it and
originally this was going to be a slimy
swamp creature he was supposed to show
Luke to not judge a book by its cover
with them eventually combining him with
a frog-like creature planned in the
original outline Stuart Freeborn
designed him and I tell you when when
you see him in this video mate you're
gonna instantly recognize the
resemblance Joel showed me a few
original sketches and uh
I thought well that's interesting but I
want something in more depth you see
and so
I looked in the mirror and I thought
well
uh
something perhaps a little bit amusing
about my face so I modeled something of
myself now I've got to make him look
intelligent I got this photograph of
Einstein and put the Einstein wrinkles
in all around
I did a lot of thinking about it because
he's got to be full of subtle action and
movements especially in the face and the
body and I put it all in what was
necessary and finally all work Frank Oz
really struggled with it because until
this point there'd never been a movie
done at this scale with a realistic
character portrayed by a puppet they
also had sound issues with Hamill being
enabled hear Yoda's voice because
Franco's had to be several feet below
the set they had to use earpieces which
they covered with his hair but in the
end that even caused issues itself I had
an earpiece where I could hear oh many
years have you ever and then if you
turned your head the wrong way you'd
pick up radio one it was the Rolling
Stone singing Fool To Cry Lucas said the
entire movie either lived or died on
Yoda and it's kind of a miracle that
they managed to get it right too old to
begin the training
I'm not afraid
oh
you will be
you will be sorry
um snakes on the sad also cause trouble
too with one even biting Hammel at one
point I'm tired of these
snakes on this set and
beyond that Hamill got really really
annoyed according to IMDb trivia he had
to bang his head 16 times on the others
hurt before kirschner finally got the
reaction he was after and from what I've
heard the guy was completely miserable
and set he was the only actor on the
call sheet for 99 of these parts and he
spent a lot of the movie on his own away
from the other actors a Franco's
originally wasn't supposed to provide
the other's voice but Lucas ended up
enjoying the performance and thus he
stuck with it Lucas actually pushed for
oz to get a Best Supporting hack to
Oscar but they ultimately rejected it
because he was just puppeteering
ironically he voiced Kermit the Frog and
Miss Piggy and when they were designing
Yoda Lucas said he saw the creatures
being there illegitimate child and the
voice thing is similar to what happened
with C3PO in the first film with Anthony
Daniels so winning Lucas round now out
of the whole cast only Hamill and Fisher
was signed on for sequels with board
refusing to do a multi-picture deal due
to bad experiences in the past he
actually wanted his character to get
killed off and the reason he was frozen
in carbonite was because they genuinely
didn't know whether he'd do a third film
Lucas of course refused to Ari kellhan
and he promised Ford a much bigger
heroic part for that third film David
prowse was also very apprehensive too
with him feeling like he was more of
just a prop rather than being an actual
performer prowse's voice was of course
replaced by James Earl Jones but fearing
they might recast if he refused he ended
up signing on Earl Jones actually felt
bad for taking money for his work in the
movie and he apparently refused to be
credited when the film was first
released he also only accepted fifteen
thousand dollars pay for what he saw as
being just a couple of hours in a
recording booth Alec Guinness was
someone who also didn't take a salary
and instead he got 0.25 of the film's
final gross due to his failing ice side
he only worked a couple of hours on set
and this was seen as a way that both
sides could win this is of course a
similar deal to what he had on a new Hub
but even a 0.25 ownership of this led to
big bucks in the end Guinness and over
100 million dollars which is equivalent
to about 370 million today
hello there now as always the production
was plagued with problems too and though
they had space booked out at elstree
Studios this clashed with the filming of
The Shining that took up most of the
space there and the Star Wars team were
forced to give up two stages so that
they could then film they actually
pulled across some of the snow sets from
that movie though and a couple of
moments on Hearth are pieces from that
film poor weather delayed the
construction though and this was also
seen in Norway where they filmed some of
the hot scenes getting hit with the
worst snowstorm in half a century the
production was blasted with blizzards
and 40 mile an hour winds camera lenses
iced over and paint froze and it's tin
making everything even more difficult
than it was shooting on Tatooine now
being shot in Norway little little bit
of heavy spoilers trivia our own Simon a
Berman who helped us out on our bad
batch videos is Godfather Ian Liston
actually played Wes Jensen Simon
actually helps make movies out of Norway
and he's massively helped out this
channel so it was really cool getting
hit with this extra bit of heavy
spoilers history now being a Jedi is all
about patience and mindfulness that's
why this video is sponsored by better
help to bring you This brilliant deal
with our online therapy sessions I
haven't really talked about this much on
the channel before but back in 2019 I
actually got diagnosed with anxiety
which made a lot of things in my life
suddenly make sense I'd always be
stressed out and worried about things
and I used to panic if I was late or if
I fell behind on a deadline just talking
about it has really helped me to deal
with it without medication and I feel a
thousand times better than I did just a
couple of years ago now regardless if
you have a clinical mental issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who's going through a tough time
in life right now because let's be
honest the world's a bit all over the
place at the moment therapy can give you
the tools to approach your life in a
completely different way better help
easy helps you find a therapist and it
can match you with the right one for you
working online through an app better
help allows sessions to be remote and
means that you can balance it around
your life signing up is easy too and you
can get matched with a fair a pest in
just a couple of days the link in the
description right now will take you to
betterhelp.com heavy spoilers and it's
going to give you 10 off your very first
month it's a perfect time to try it out
get connected and see if therapy can
help you out they will so easily allow
you to change your therapist if you
don't feel like things are working out
so you can find the one that's the right
fit for you an additional cost you can
swap your therapist and go with someone
else if you feel you've gained
everything that you need to if you've
ever been curious about therapy or have
tried it in the past then this is the
perfect opportunity to take it up and
see if it can change your life again go
to betterhelp.com heavy spoilers and get
10 off your first month that's
betterhealth.com heavy spoilers and get
that 10 off your very first month huge
thank you to better help for supporting
the channel and thank you everyone who
checks that deal out peace and that
takes us into the movie itself which
begins with the text of episode 5 in the
classic title crawl back in 1977 A New
Hope didn't actually come with that name
and instead the movie was just titled
Star Wars adding this end gave the idea
that it was a grander story and upon
re-releases Lucas and added in the
episode 4 and New Hope titling now I
don't know if it's just me but watching
the 4K Blu-ray on my OLED really made
the space scenes pop this week with the
stars burning and blinking in the
background and made making that style
crawl really stand out beginning with
the text it's a dark time for the
Rebellion this instantly lets us another
tone for the film and that'll be taking
things down to its lowest point the
movie actually bombed a lot of people
out upon its release and received quite
a few negative reviews for where it took
the characters you can kind of see why
as the first movie was so beat and it
started the grand tradition of people
complaining about Star Wars no one hates
Star Wars more than Star Wars fans and
Lucas actually issued an apology for how
it made people feel after cutting to the
Imperials we once more see a star
destroyer and watch his probe dry to
sense searching for Skywalker like bugs
descending and spreading out we learn
Empires sent thousands of these across
the Galaxy desperately hunting for him
the idea of them being like insect bug
things is of course carried across to
their design with the appearance of
their moving appearing spider-like due
to all the eyes whereas I know it's an
arachnid yet but whereas the first film
tried to do the comedic Geo of 3PO and
R2 to start the film this probe Droid
has a far more Sinister side to it
[Music]
if you read the transcripts you can
actually figure out what it's saying and
the line apparently is scan into the
system I can see the rebel base now the
probe going to Hoth Echoes the shot and
you hope of the Escape pod crashing down
on Tatooine this gives us the idea this
movie will be an opposite of the first
as that had a hot desert Planet whereas
this is a baron Iceland you should have
called it cold
he said it he said it anyway NASA
actually have a planet on their radar
that they've nicknamed Hoth which is a
super Earth planet orbiting a sun 3000
light years away now in the intro we
actually get two things crashing down
with the first probe Landing before we
cut to Luke riding a taunt on Luke sees
another thing come crashing down and
this has always made me wonder whether
this is two probes or if it's the same
one the screenplay actually clears it up
with it's staying that we see it before
we cut a Luke's perspective of the exact
same event personally yeah Steven
Spielberg over here I probably would
have just done the one but I guess it
would have been weird to show the probe
dried hatching in between these moments
before we then get the wamper attack her
ton tones were originally designed to
look lizard-like but due to how cold it
was the creative team made them carry
across sheep qualities to keep them warm
when crafting the creatures they lurked
out a lot of different designs with him
originally settling on the beast at the
necron 99 rode in in the 1970s film
Wizards at this point Luke gets attacked
by the Wampa who itself was based on the
Abominable Snowman is it abominable now
filming with these creatures was a
complete Nightmare and Lucas ended up
having to cut around a lot of them due
to how bad they looked on camera but the
special edition they went back and
re-shot several moments with them
including the cave scene which he was
originally completely absent of the
moments where to crouch down eating
something
oh
they made a much smaller set for this so
that the Wampa would seem bigger with
ilms Howie weed playing the part of the
creature Lucas originally only wanted to
do a special edition version of A New
Hope but they saw the benefits of
re-releasing these movies due to the big
bucks they got back on them however he
was kind of pushed time wise to get the
other ones done which is why balthus and
Jedi have fewer changes in them now
wampers were gonna play a much bigger
part and originally there were gonna be
some lines of dialogue where we
discovered that they'd attacked Echo
base at one point when Hans walking to
find out about Luke you can catch a dead
one on the ground and this was supposed
to be in the aftermath of one of their
ambushes there was also a deleted scene
involving whompers trapped in a room
which C3PO would use as a way to trick
some of the snow troopers
[Music]
thank you
now Luke hanging upside down is a motif
that repeats throughout the movie and it
always comes at transformative points in
his life the first time hears him
reaching out and using the force to pull
his lightsaber which is the first time
we'd seen something like this in the
Saga this then leads to Ben speaking
directly to him and this is so he can
move on to the next part of his training
that involves Yoda with him doing an
upside down handstand and wants more
having to tap into the force as part of
that training the last time comes after
he learns Vader as his father and he
hangs upside down underneath Cloud City
in order to escape this he has to use
the force to speak to Leia and again
it's sort of like poetry they Rhyme now
Luke's costume here also highlights is
changing with it being a mix between
gray and white this is something that we
see evolved throughout the original
trilogy with a character wearing all
white in that very first movie okay on
the end of this it's shifted to fully
gray with Jedi being where he ends up
donning all black it's a really good
progression of his color scheme and it
also hints to the yard audience that he
loses the Innocence he's once had now
cutting off the one bizarre this neatly
foreshadows his hand being lost and it
slips in the idea that lightsabers can
do this I know that it happened with
Obi-Wan in the last movie but they're
really hammering at home here so it fits
in with the end now when Luke escapes
who watch him run out into a blizzard
which was a real one happening in the
area the crew talked about how they all
huddled in Huts whilst Tamil had to do
this and they torn taunted him about him
freezing his nuts off Knight Echo base
we hear solo mentioning Jabba the hurt
and also the Bounty Hunter Arnold mantel
I thought you were decided to stay well
the Bounty Hunter we ran into an
ordinand I'll change my mind this is
somewhere that you visit in Shadows of
the Empire with Dash render riding on
the back of a train to take him to the
central part of the junkyard upon
arriving there you face off against rg88
which was clearly riffing on this line
from Empire the story with the group
running into a bad D Hunter would later
be explained with a radio show title
Rebel mission to ord mantel this Dropped
In 83 and have featured most of the
original cast and retold this story we
actually get a bit of a clue to the
Rivalry between the bounty hunters later
on and you can actually catch what looks
like ig-88 on Cloud City in the room
where the Argonauts are dismantling the
Droid if you look just by the furnace
you can actually see the machine lying
there now in the expanded lore it was
explained that ig-88 arrived at Cloud
City tailing Fair which is when the pair
juked it out with the ladder winning
however there's conflicting reports over
this with it also being said to be ig-86
in Shadows of the Empire Dash actually
destroys 88 so yeah you can kind of pick
your poison with that and decide who
this body is for you now we also get the
romance between hanalea which is player
baton throughout this entire movie
canonically this is set three years
after the first film and Lucas wondered
about these characters together which is
why they barely share scenes with Luke
there is still that whole thing with the
kiss though which will just chalk up to
being based on Greek myths to be fair
neither knew that they were related and
it does kind of push on a layer to
accept that they like each other now
Carrie Fisher actually stood in a box
for a lot of the scenes with Ford
because it turned out he was an entire
foot taller than her I love Han's
moments where he's getting annoyed by
Chewie because they just want to leave
and though he's wanting to sort things
out with Jabba the mood changes when he
learns looks missing you really get the
friendship that these people have built
between the movies with Han genuinely
worried that Luke's out on his own I'm
not sure what the whole idea of Hell in
this universe is based around but even
Hans saying this just uh it really hits
home we're gonna see you in hell yeah
lets you know that he's willing to risk
it all and just that scene where the
door closes it adds so much with
Chewie's agonizing cry showing how much
he cares about the character
now before it goes down we get to the
rebels discussing that they've had no
word and on the right John rattenberger
who played cliff in cheers not really
much of an Easter egg but Obi-Wan
delivers his message and I've always
thought it was so cool how han appeared
behind him I don't know if I'll be one
in the blizzard was what Drew him to
Luke or if he just dropped the message
because he knew he was coming but it's
such a great transition from one
character to the other I doubt it's
because Han sees him but you know we try
and look at it from all angles though he
probably would have seen the ghost in
the Jedi if he could see ghosts either
way he also busts out Luke's lightsaber
and as a kid I always remember playing
as him and doing like the odd thing with
it because I thought hon at least still
could smash about with one if the
situation corporate now I always like
the idea that Han saved looked from
getting Frozen but in the end Luke
failed to return the favor Arthur
encased in something that keeps them
alive but one goes off to a darker fate
or Asia that doesn't Owen manages to
save Luke using the old survival trick
of sleeping in and animals in heads and
this was something that they also showed
in the Revenant Now One Touch of Lucas
did was the color of Hans cold as this
basically became the first blue or gold
dress back in the day the toys had a
blue coat whereas some people swore that
it was brown in the film but the special
editions they turned up the blue heel to
match the toys because that's the main
thing that people tend to remember nice
bit of trivia for you there and the next
day we see the snow Speeders heading out
and are introduced to rug too
this is Rogue two this would have cause
gone to influence the name Rogue
Squadron and also Rogue one which
centered around the rebels little little
bit of cheeky costume design here but
you can catch bubble wraps on the
shoulder straps that he's riding around
with now Luke is placed in a bacter tank
and these have been laced throughout the
Saga with with don't get me started on
bucker Boba Fett makers like every every
time something got interesting it you
just go back to the tank now Gareth
Edwards also had one appear in Rogue one
and Obi-Wan later used it to reintroduce
Veda with those scenes riffing on his
son here again I will be talking about
how some of these moments pay off in the
other movies down the line as it's
unlikely I'll ever cover them in depth
or talk about them on a breakdown I know
it does some of you guys heading when I
mentioned stuff like The Last Jedi but
I'll try and keep it to a minimum as we
go through the breakdown now Han tells
Luke don't look so bad to me and he
looks strong enough to pull ears off a
gun dark which is a giant Rancor like
Beast that comes from the planet vancore
now obviously you guys know yeah I just
have to put a disclaimer in this movie
was shot in 1980 so some of the elements
are a little bit dated they're a little
bit problematic shall we say and Leia
calls Han and Nerf herder at one point
which look I apologize if you're
watching this we just have to use the
word in context to explain what she
meant now a Nerf herder was someone who
herded Nerfs and this was seen as a
lower class profession that didn't
require any skills or competence this
became an insult throughout the Galaxy
though I've never used that word in my
entire life I've never even thought it
and I'm definitely never said it when
I've wrapped along with a song on the
radio now after picking up the probe
Droid we also get this line in row 10
and 11 to station 3A which is a
reference to George Lucas's film THX
1138 this was also dropped in A New Hope
showing that it's all connected
now after destroying the pro we cut the
Star Destroyers in space and literally
see how they are overshadowed by veda's
new vessel the Superstar Destroyer
completely engulfs all and one of its
hyperdrive engines recently popped up in
Ahsoka we've actually just launched a
new a soccer inspired t-shirt just below
on the merch store right under the video
and every sale helps you look slick and
helps videos like this get made make
sure you send us pictures of your
rocking on Twitter as well and we can
drop them in the videos as a big thank
you to say you know what we appreciate
your support now accompanying this is
various Imperial March which was based
on the planet's Mars bringer of War
foreign
between the officers and Vader just
calmly shutting down any of The Descent
just some things are done militaristic
about the whole thing and even his spin
to catch a guy standing very close
behind him it's just like everyone's
fixated on what he says now we get a
cameo back at Echo base with Concept
artist wrath Macquarie walking through a
scene in his hand he's holding a
Sketchbook and according to the Legends
this container's original drawings we
can also see Han fixing up the Falcon
and can catch a periscope Droid which
appeared in A New Hope This is actually
a final farewell between Luke and Han
and they wouldn't actually see each
other again until Return of the Jedi
back on the ship we see is available
Force chokes Admiral Ozil calling back
to him doing it to krennic in the first
movie kinda I kind of smirked watching
this back do you know seeing Ozil slowly
die while Raider just keeps barking
orders and nobody around Aussie tries to
step in and help him out kindly shows
how Imperials are aren't exactly
bothered about labor laws but we
actually get a really subtle detail that
builds off this scene Piet is promoted
from Captain to Admiral and later on the
characters got a slightly extended patch
at this point the aradats arrived with
him being designed and filmed in stop
motion by Phil Tippett according to
Tibet he based them off the alien
walkers in War of the Worlds and also on
Gantry Crane's witchland ship docks
studying elephants they wanted their
movement as realistic as possible and
they're some of the most memorable
things that we encounter in this film a
little cool thing they do is that when
they target The Shield generator we can
actually see the Blaster bolts way
bigger than the standard shots now
suddenly Lucas lets us know that the
rebels are screwed here as the first
thing we see them do is evacuating the
planet the entire speeder scene is
simply to buy them time and rather than
being like a heroic battle from the
first film their only interests escaping
now I do poop on I do poop on the
special editions a bit but one thing it
allowed them to do in these moments was
tidy up the effects originally the mat
on the ships and Walkers wasn't as
developed as it is now and you could
actually see them through the parts of
the cockpit they clean this up for the
re-releases with transparency now being
completely removed but if you had the
old special edition VHS then you'll know
they discussed it on that luckily for
you if you don't have it I actually dug
out the old tape but a warning here some
of these clips may be in 480p a
challenge when we did it because nobody
had ever done uh blue screen matting on
a white surface usually do it on dark
surfaces
foreign
we used Optical technology of course to
do all that compositing and a Telltale
sign that something's been optically
composited is a black line around it and
when you have a sequence that takes
place in outer space against Stars it's
easy to reach a point where those black
lines don't show up
but when you have a sequence that takes
place against snow in the daylight every
hint of that that black matte line
becomes very visible and so the first
time through doing the doing the snow
battle here 17 years ago a lot of effort
went into finding ways to minimize that
black line one of the ways was to not
print all of the elements at their full
opacity oh I'm coming in consequently
when you see the snow battle on film you
may notice that there's part of the the
scenery is visible through the cockpit
and it was a constant trade-off of how
transparent can we make the cockpit at
what point is the black line more
objectionable than the transparency and
so there was an opportunity to go back
into those shots use the computer
technology and eliminate all the
transparency but also not have any matte
lines
[Music]
now during this attack we also get our
first Wilhelm scream which is something
that appears throughout almost every
movie
[Music]
we also meet Luke's co-pilot Dak who
always felt like he was brought in so
they could just kill him for this battle
he's actually named after editor Dwayne
Dunham's dog Dak and this brings a sort
of biplane aesthetic to the ships Dennis
Lawson also returns after fan interests
due to him being one of the only
survivors from the Death Star Mission
I'm sure you know but just in case you
don't Lawson's actually you McGregor's
Uncle who of course played Obi-Wan now
all the scenes involving explosions with
them such as when Luke throws a thermal
detonator underwater and the down one
blows up they had to be shot using
different techniques due to them being
Miniatures they had to be filmed on
high-speed cameras which were then
slowed down to make the tiny explosions
look big also I know there's some back
and forth on the pronunciation of
whether it's at at or 8080 with Lucas
saying it's in fact pronounced atat I
don't think they care though because
like loads of these names get pronounced
differently even from scene to scene Han
gets called Han I actually call him Han
but I've been purposely calling him hard
throughout the video just to avoid
comments and Donald Glover actually made
a joke about this during the movie solo
Billy D Williams accidentally called him
Han and no one corrected it so Glover
did the same thing in Solo which Han
then corrected they always have a moment
where Billy D Williams calls him Han and
you could tell it throws everyone off in
the scene because they all start doing
the same thing
now the Accents in general they tend to
decide how something's said and it was
actually during this movie that
kirschner made sure to make decides have
distinctive ones in A New Hope Leia has
a more British sounding voice but
carrying this movie leans into her
actual one occasional mate should have
all the rebels speaking American and all
of the Imperials speaking with a British
accent this was done to make the story
an analog to the American Revolution and
even though a lot of the actors in the
hot scenes were British they actually
ended up redubbing a lot of the actors
to keep up this consistency you can spot
this when the guy sees the adad and his
mouth doesn't move along with what he's
saying Echo station 3ta Echo station 3pa
amongst the ads we can also spot atsds
which you know looking back maybe it
should be pronounced 8080. either way
they play a much bigger role in the
follow-up film and Lucas actually filmed
more scenes involving them just for this
movie however he found the Adda to a
formal menacing realizing the smaller
ones would be better for Close Quarters
combat after that dies we get a really
heroic moment with Luke where he shows
he's capable of taking down an 8080
single-handedly I'm just going to call
them 8080s because that's what I feel I
should do and from now on I'm also
calling him Han don't Boo don't Boo Boo
this man
foreign
up and it shows how skill that he's
becoming as a fighter we also get a
moment where a walker shoots down a
speeder and I just love the stop-motion
here where tilts and takes it out looks
really cool and it also changes the tone
of the scene to give the Imperials the
upper hand The Shield generators
destroyed and we then cut back to the
base where we see Han and Co desperately
racing to the Falcon the snow troopers
storm in and the uniforms were actually
based around German Troopers who were
sent to the front lines to fight the war
with Russia might be a reach but I
always felt they looked like KKK cloaks
as well with the point being removed
from the top of their heads either way
hanba saw one of the Falcon Surprises
with a gun dropping down from underneath
the ship This was later riffed on in the
force awakens with us getting a similar
one dropping out of Poe's X-Wing the
Falcon escaping also transitions
perfectly into Luke seeing a take off
and yeah just some really tight
storytelling taking us from one
character to the next on Luke's X-Wing
we can also catch the markings ZZ which
in the the universe is arabesh for our
this could be related to the rebels but
so far no one's found out what it
actually means but if you know then drop
it below now the Falcon flies into space
which is where we see it's pursued by a
bunch of typewriters throughout the film
3pos been constantly trying to tell how
the hyperdrive's not working which means
they have to fly directly into an
asteroid field and the failed jump comes
with the stock sound effect of a plane
starting up to which I'm sure they were
used in Raiders of the Lost Ark watch
this
get lots of slapstick comedy with the
tools smacking up Anne's head which lets
us know they're heading towards the
asteroid really love how C-3PO gives the
odds for survival as well and after
doing it earlier this kind of becomes
this catchphrase whenever I think of him
he's giving the odds and yeah I love the
banter and dialogue between the whole
crew here now the asteroid field pushed
the creative team to the Limit and they
had to build a new version of the Falcon
that could pull off these complex twists
and turns who watches these Maneuvers
cause the star destroys to almost crash
into each other and these almost appear
like their teeth kinda feel like this
foreshadows the space slug Escape later
on and how its jaws almost close around
the ship that's right themselves
apparently had some that were made out
of potatoes and even one of the VFX
artists shoes are in there now we even
get a moment where a TIE fighter flies
directly into an asteroid and you can
catch the pilot getting flung out into
space to me this is also where William
scorly sings and it's probably one of my
favorite pieces in this entire franchise
[Music]
now back on the Star Destroyer we see
Vader's meditation chamber and get a
brief Glimpse at the back of his head
apparently the sound effects for this
use there's an entire block of Alcatraz
doors slamming shut and seeing Vader
like this is another hint to the subtext
Ian Luke are of course related and
they're both shown to be scarred and
inside of a white chamber the atmosphere
in here is altered which is why Vader
can breathe without his helmet however
he does have a small mask that we see
being pulled up as we get the shot of
his head such a funny detail happens
here when we cut to an establishing shot
of the asteroid field and can see a star
destroyer being hit directly with one we
then jumped overhead talking to
Holograms of his Admirals and catch the
guide of the left reacting to the impact
before the transmission cuts off just a
nice little bit of dark humor and it
also shows how little Radar really gives
a about his underlings Aveda ends
up moving out the asteroid field to
speak with the emperor which is when we
get one of the big special edition
changes originally the emperor was
played by Marjorie Eaton with M
superimposing chimpanzee eyes over her
face This was later referenced in Rise
of Skywalker when we had a chimpanzee
face kylo's helmet with a visor over its
eyes Clive Revel provided the voice with
the scene and dialogue later being
updated to have a McDermott now there
are some line changes here so it expands
more on Luke and also him being The
Offspring of Anakin Skywalker we have a
new enemy
Luke Skywalker we have a new enemy
the young rebel who destroyed the Death
Star
s this boy is
the brain of Anakin Skywalker now
originally Anakin wasn't mentioned in
name until Return of the Jedi with
Obi-Wan's Force ghost saying it for the
first time really clunky mcclunky you
could say and yeah I kind of prefer the
way that they had it originally anyway
on dagobar are to get swallowed by a
swamp creature which in the expanded
lore is known as a haggabad this is
actually an anagram of dagobar and
something else got altered in these
scenes too if you saw this movie in the
theaters then you might remember Luke
dropping a line about R2 not tasting
very good
you're lucky you don't taste very good
you were lucky to get out of there now
while this was changed is because when
the movie was originally sent out
different prints had slightly different
sound mixes when they made the special
editions they ended up picking the one
with the final line though personally I
still prefer the original now Luke says
that he feels there's something familiar
about this place and its strong
connection to the force likely gives his
notion he can also sense that they're
being watched showing how his connection
to it has been improved Luke then runs
Indiana and Lucas has kept a lot of his
species backstory a mystery I love how
Yoda just plays about with him and this
is all done as a test to see if Luke has
any patience Luke failed by getting
angry and frustrated and this is when he
reveals that he can't teach him I cannot
teach him
boy has no patience Yoda really embodies
the teachings of the Jedi which
themselves were based around the Eastern
ideologies of self-defense martial arts
like karate and Judo you know the key
word with them is defense because you're
not meant to go on the attack and use
them to bully people this is why when we
see others training it mainly involves
running a meditation rather than going
on the offensive and practicing sparring
even a little floating draw that Luke
practiced with in a new hope that was
all about blocking and it's rare that
the Jedi are supposed to go on the
attack now when we first cut to Yoda in
his backpack we can also see a winged
creature known as a dagbat who questions
whether the dark side is stronger
because from what he's seen evil makes
things easier however like Yoda says
it's more difficult to master your
feelings and having power over this is
where the true control lies Yoda even
says if Luke picks up his lightsaber and
anger that it will drastically change
the course of his entire life that's
definitely the case and it actually
reflects what happens when Luke goes in
the cave Luke was told to not take
weapons with him but doing this showed
why he got what he got as Yoda says only
what to take with you
a Luke went looking for a fight unless
he found one this summer foreshadows the
ending as he purposely goes looking for
a battle with Vader and in the end
that's what he finds the cave shows you
your darkest thoughts and that explains
why Luke sees a vision of himself in the
mask now they actually tried to use a
prosthetic head for this but it looked
too unrealistic when it was revealed
thus Hamill had to stick his head out
the ground and then sit with a mask
covering his face however this proved to
be really difficult as he wasn't allowed
to Blink even with all that smoke
blowing in his face and there's actually
a hint that this Vader is fake and we
can hear that his breathing is slightly
different
his lightsaber is also colored a bit
more orange looking and this gives off
the effect that it's more of a vision
than reality a purpose he made this
Vision die in a similar way to Obi-Wan
which makes it seem like Luke's becoming
more like his dad now Luke's face inside
Vader's helmet also highlights the
connection between him and his dad and
it helps set up the theme of the next
two movies which is about the Father and
Son relationship beta of course wants to
make his son come over to the dark side
and the word Vader actually means father
in Dutch though it is pronounced
differently I also love how his Vader
walks out the cave we can see as the
environment creates these slanted
archways later on when Luke fights him
down the card on bespin we can also see
the archways return to build off this
moment and the following scene is Luke
trying to lift the X-Wing out the Borg
and Frank Oz does so much with the
Puppeteer just the look of shock really
carries across and it's moments like
this that embody the true power of a
Jedi I keep telling my wife that size
Matters not and we see that in the case
of Yoda the ship and the timeline of
this is a bit all over the place as the
Falcon manages to get the best spin
without the use of a hyperdrive people
obviously wonder how long of a trip in
space that is but lucasfilm have
actually never nailed down how long it
took alongside the training it's thought
to be about three days so like I said
it's never been confirmed now Luke
clearly hates all of his training and
yeah maybe you should have taken the
online course instead of going to the
planet he ignores both the warnings of
Obi-Wan and Yoda and decides to leave
which is when we get this clue about
Leia that boy is our last hope no
there is another
foreign
as the next character we see after this
line is actually Leia they do some
overly long shots of the X-Wing going to
space followed by some Cloud City
moments but the next time that we see
someone it is her in the window now
Lucas put this line in not only to elude
to this but he also wanted the audience
to feel like Luke could actually die
doing this might make us think they were
going to replace him which is a nice
little way to raise tensions for the
fight no he's establishing shots in this
special edition at least we see it about
a gas platform which mine it from the
planet Below in Rogue Squadron they had
a mission where you had to attack
Imperial containers on these and the gas
in general plays another fight at the
end the Carbonite chamber is full of it
and this is actually what Luke sprays
Invaders face during their duel a Vader
ends up calling in lots of bandhanas
including characters like bosk his
costume was actually grabbed from The
Archives of Doctor Who with them then
adding the lizard mask to top off the
look fat ig-88 and dangor are also there
as well with a ladder having a rivalry
with Solo in the expanded lore a Fat's
voice was redubbed after attack of the
Clones to make it so that he sounded
more like Tamira Morrison looking back I
actually prefer the original I don't
know watching with Morrison it it does
kind of take me out of it even though I
like the actor you may take Captain solo
to Jabba the Hut after I have Skywalker
good to meet Dad he's no good to me dead
what if he doesn't survive he's worth a
lot to me what if he doesn't survive he
learned a lot to me across space we
joined the Millennium Falcon hiding out
on a slug lots of clear allusions to
Pinocchio in this with a creature even
appearing well like when we see it later
on tripio talks to the Falcon and in
this movie you really get the feeling
that it's its own character it breaks
down chugs along talks to the Droid and
takes on a bit of a life of its own sir
I don't know where your ship then to
communicate but it has the most peculiar
dialect this dialogue with a ship would
later get expanded on in solo with l337
getting uploaded into it Han and Leia
have their first kiss to a bit of John
Williams which is then interrupted by
C-3PO now on the outside of the asteroid
we watch his bombers sweep the area
which was a new Thai design created for
this film this was actually based on the
World War II German boss bv-141
reconnaissance bomber which had a deal
fuselage to that these also carry now
this is of course coming from World War
II aesthetic and the Stormtrooper
blasters themselves are based on a
sterling l2a3 MK love this line by hand
as well so if I may Venture an opinion
am I really interested in your opinion
and after fighting my knocks on the ship
Han realizes they're inside the belly of
the Beast and they make a dash for it
the noise of monarchs was actually
created by playing a horse Grunt and
then reversing it which you can kinda
hear
[Music]
these masks that they're wearing would
later appear in The Saga with Ryan Finn
using them in force away you're gonna
get so much for mentioning the
sequels but that's that's where the
problem again anyway after they escape
we see the Falcon being chased by
destroyers and they pull off a desperate
maneuver to get out of this situation
hiding on the back of a star destroyer
this was a technique Lucas reused but
I'll be one in the prequel trilogy
retroactively I think this was dropped
into attack of the Clones the show why
Bubba was able to suss out the Falcon
doing the same tactic down the line
slave one appears in both of these films
with its color scheme reflecting the
armor of its owner in both instances now
the crew flyer to Bear spin after hand
suggests it with Chewbacca hitting at
the history between him and Lando this
is expanded upon them more in Solo
they're seeing how han actually won the
falcon
well that was a long time ago I'm sure
he's forgotten about that as we know the
character cheated but he used Lando's
tactics so fair is fair now they're also
escorted him by Cloud cars which are
atmospheric cars produced by bespin
Motors Reddit user xenomorphosaurus
theorized that the Falcon was fired upon
our first because Lando was actually
trying to warn them off from it the
Empire would of course want them to land
so this aggressive tactic might be the
only thing Lando could do now again
but yeah let me know below exactly what
you think a cloud city actually builds
off the back of a concept from the first
film with it originally being conceived
as a prison above Alderaan this is where
Obi-Wan invader's deal was gonna go down
but it was just all pushed into the
Death Star for some economic
storytelling now lots of this approach
was redone for the special editions with
them also changing out the background so
it showed more of the city greeted by
Lando I feel like this was the role that
got Billy D that cult 45 career here we
awesome it is a lobot who's got
cybernetic Parts placed over his head in
the movie This covers his entire ears
and ironically the actor John Hollis did
something similar in the past ollis also
played a clitus observer in Flash Gordon
but in that he had a cybernetic device
over his eyes the banter between the
pair instantly comes through and we get
a sort of love triangle with Lando in
the mix now in the scene while Lano
takes Leia's hand Han grabs it off him
and we get a little smile from Carrie
Fisher this moment of hand grabbing her
was apparently improvised in the moment
which caught her off God and caused it a
bright character not really breaking but
you know what I mean and the smile here
seems genuine instead of being acted
given a lush white Penthouse it's clear
landos trying to win them around with
comfort so that they stay longer for the
Empire to put things in place even says
delayer absolutely beautiful
you truly belong here with us among the
clouds thank you handing out the part of
the deal of how they now have to remain
prisoner there taking a dinner there
immediately agreed by Vader and I
absolutely love the way this scene plays
out it shows just how quick to draw that
hand is whilst also cementing Vader's
true strength on verse Vader as a
matchup that you'd never really think to
see and even watching it here you can
instantly see why even though he's one
of the best characters in The Saga he's
got no chats and rarely just blocks his
Blaster bolts by lifting his hand he's
made you look a right knob I've always
kind of taken this as being akin to
bullets bouncing off Superman and it
sets up the idea that Luke doesn't stand
a chance now from this point Hans
interrogated or tortured due to them not
really asking any questions
he never even asked me any questions
[Music]
this is purely because Vader wanted to
learn Luke and he knew doing this would
give him visions of his friends
suffering they'd be absolutely no point
in asking him anything which is why he
just torches him instead of staying
there chichang now from here he's taken
to be frozen which is when Princess Leia
says I love you you probably already
know this because you're very far deep
into a Star Wars video but just in case
you don't here's what happened with
Han's reply there was a moment in it
when Han Solo was about to be cast into
a object later to be purchased by
William kurtzman and artsy
made into frozen into carbonite and
finally the princess reveals her great
love for him and her line is I love you
and George had artfully contrived for
Han Solo to say I love you too right
no not for you well I thought it was a
lost opportunity yeah sure I mean this
character never behaved so unabashedly
emotional and unconventional uh before
and I thought are we pissing away this
great opportunity for the for the
character you want your bad asses to be
a badass to the end do you want him to
go down uh the way they the way they
lived
so I I said I mean what's the last thing
a woman wants to hear when she says I
love you
she says I love you and I say
I know right and so we shot you shot one
like that right well we shot one you
know just for protection where I spoke
the line uh as written and George I
think that this is a fair enough to say
he went ape he thought it was
horrible and that it would get a bad
laugh so I was obliged to sit next to
him when he tested it for the first
screening there was a laugh but it was a
laugh of recognition kind of ties back
to him teasing her before come on you
want me to stay because of the way you
feel about me and something about the
way he's dumped down almost like a
living death where he's become part of
the coffin it just sticks in your mind
as a big point in this movie just the
drool and the look of pain on his face
froze and it is something that's always
been part of my memory and every time I
think back at this movie this is one of
the first things that pops up it's
almost like a frozen Agony with this
being such an impactful way to close out
his Arc in the film this would later be
ripped upon in Solo a Star Wars story
when the character Falls in some mud and
poses in a similar position you also see
a really subtle change in Lando here as
he grabs his neck after Vader tells him
he's altered the deal typically people
do this when they feel vulnerable and it
might show that the constant changes
have now gone too far beta has also
choked out multiple people in this movie
too and it could be symbolically
building off that to show how close he
is to getting it done to him now this
scene is also the only moment in the
Original Trilogy Where Vader and 3PO are
on screen together watching the prequels
and knowing what we know I thought he
would have been like oh is that 3PO
That's my boy after this moment Luke
sneaks through the location which is
where he sees Han's body being escorted
through as he draws his Blaster we see
fat turn his head and this is because he
actually hears the gun getting pulled
out this is why he goes back and starts
shooting and it's such a cool detail to
show how aware he is funnily enough Luke
poses Blaster out throughout the movie
at several points but he never actually
fires it throughout the entire film now
the battle between Luke and Veda is shot
brilliantly with this getting the two
different sides almost in every aspect
blue and red are the two key colors here
with both blades representing dark and
light this is carried across to the
environment too with a blue background
clashing with the reddish glow of the
stairs the reddish glow can also be seen
invader's Superstar Destroyer with the
engines of it appearing the same color
at roughly the 22 minute Mark later
fights with just one hand egg suiting
confidence and it's clear that he's just
toying with his new Padawan however
after Luke trixom he goes back to using
two showing that he slowly realizes he
needs to take the fight more seriously
the longer it goes on the tougher it
gets with radar even getting to the
point that he just starts throwing stuff
at him he also disarms him which causes
Luke to drop his blade and this
disarming moves a trick that he does
later on other Luke refuses to let go of
it and the second time Vader disarms him
by literally disarming him after Luke
falls down the stairs we get a little
moment where we can actually see him
looking above Vader's head it's a very
subtle glance but it telegraphs his next
move which is to jump above him after he
gets dropped in the pit now the shot of
Luke pulling the lightsaber to his hand
was actually achieved by Hamill just
throwing it and then reversing the
footage bit of a gaff in the Carbonite
chamber but when it when it goes into
his hand if you slow it down yet you can
see it lighting before he actually grabs
it nitpick it's a nitpick and also
taunts Luke about his training with
Obi-Wan Obi-Wan this is because he's
unaware that Yoda was doing it and he
still thinks it's his previous master
who was teaching him now later on the
pair gets separated and Vader actually
hides from Luke down one of the
corridors upon appearing his breathing
speeds up and this is because the
character has been holding his breath
and not give away where he is
[Music]
these cardos would again appear in Rey's
Vision in the force awakens just before
she discovered Luke's lightsaber which
gets lost shortly after this scene
standing look out the window we can see
how far this fall was as you can catch
it in the top left when we cut the
establishing shot when he's hanging you
can also see his lightsaber just sitting
on the walkway explaining how he managed
to get it back after this fall now while
this is going on Lando ends up helping
the rebels escape and we watch as he
races after the Falcon with them at the
end we see him wearing Hans clothes and
for years I was like whoa that's that's
a bit cold mate now but what the
theory is is that Lano left his home
with just the clothes on his back so he
would have had to fish around in hand
stuff in order to get a change of them
not like I needed them and I actually
heard they smell better on the inside
and just before rushing through the
corridors or to get electrocuted on the
power socket and this moment was summing
out of appeared in the original
novelization for a New Hope in the end
Lucas didn't end up using it but he
brought it across for this film after
thinking it was a funny gag racing
through the corridors Lando runs past
the character will roll her now we can
see that he's carrying a container turns
out right this is actually an ice cream
maker but it's something that's been
actively now brought into the franchise
as being a container that holds stuff
popped up in Battlefront where he could
get rewards from it and the Klein also
had one in the Mandalorian now cutting
back to the fight Luke actually gets
first blood and he manages to cut
Vader's shoulder which is when he
realizes that he has to wrap things up
throughout the battle he's just been
toying with his son but he finally
realizes the kid could beat him and
decides to end it there cutting off his
hand we then get the big talking pun of
this movie with the twist being revealed
that Vader's Luke's father spoiler alert
now this was kept completely unwraps
from everyone and said except for Mark
Hamill who was actually told the reveal
just moments before shooting the line
used on set was no Obi-Wan killed your
father but it then being dubbed over by
James Earl Jones David prause he was a
bit annoyed he got kept in the dark
because he said he'd have played it
differently to make the body language
more impactful Amma actually said that
when he and Ford first watched the movie
that he leaned over and said hey cude
you never told me that James L
Jones was so sure that Vader was lying
that he actually thought it wasn't true
until he read the sequel script I love
how devastating this moment is even now
and everything about it is carried
across perfectly even just the way the
Imperial March changes to give it this
more impactful feel we we slowly started
to see as Luke realizes it's true
I am your father
[Music]
now this lines became discussed in a lot
of collective false memory syndrome
because most people swear it's Luke I am
your father even James Earl Jones said
it but yeah no mention of Luke in the
entire thing now another reason this
whole thing's so painful to Luke is
because he realizes that Obi-Wan has
lied to him this was someone he looked
up to and trusted and now he really
doesn't know what he should believe Luke
says see a chump and throws himself
under the chasm showing that he'd rather
face death than join with his Dad how
about as he falls down he goes into a
shoot which could have something extra
going on with it now this is probably
down in the force but this viewing I
actually had a different Theory what if
right Vader was someone who was actually
guarding him and this because he wanted
to save his son they actually added in a
screen for the special editions but I
think this has been removed in the
latest update also lots of extra audio
in this movie is just explaining certain
things because Lucas thought people were
too stupid to get it so they just spell
it out on the special edition oh this is
suicide
oh this is Stewie tonight there's no way
to go either way he reaches out to layer
and for the special edition they added
in an extra hatch in the Falcon to block
out the white background now from this
point we get what in my personal opinion
is the the worst change in the special
editions not kidney but now Veda in
their original cut he he was Furious and
this was so well reflected in James's
slightly toned back but still angry
delivery
it's just so badass bring my shuttle but
then because Lucas was worried that
audiences wouldn't understand that it
shuttle and Star Destroyer were two
different things they changed it to this
and let my Star Destroyer prepare for my
rival
Lucas yeah he felt that he really had to
underline it and then we got added in
shuttle shot where he he flies up at the
ship and then shots of him stepping off
it these were actually unused ones from
Return of the Jedi which were then used
to help pad out the journey now reaching
out to Leia I love this shot of the
Falcon turning around on the clouds and
the type by the chase turns what what
could have been a doll rescue scene into
a really exciting one the sun coming up
behind the planet and the hyperdrive
being broken it all just add so much to
it and R2 saves a day allowing them to
jump from here we get a shot from behind
where is head which Echoes the way that
he was introduced in the movie both
scenes use the same Framing and it
brings it full circle from that
beginning guys two lost in thought about
his son to even kill Piet even though he
promised Vader they deactivate the
hyperdrive if your men deactivate the
hyperdrive on the Millennium organ
I love how after they jump he just turns
around and walks away and everyone's
just kind of staring like
is he gonna kick off honestly that
aren't really that many jokes in the
film but there's a lot of little
humorous bits like this where I just
laugh because everyone's so scared
shitless evader kind of reminds me of
when I drop an 11 000 word script on the
editors and I'm like you better
get this done in an hour's time mate or
you're dead at this point we go
to the medical frigate with Luke getting
a replacement hand put in place works
too well and he even feels pain through
it but it carries a special meaning with
it as well beta is more man the machine
and Luke is slowly starting to come
closer to his father through the
replacement of his limb though it is a
little touch it's him slowly stepping
forwards towards the vision that he had
in the cave from here we go to Luke and
Leia looking out over the Galaxy and a
feeling that they have a long road ahead
of them to go and get Han now this does
sort of have a bit of sweet feeling to
it and it's not as dour as it originally
was Hammer actually said they shot this
moment four months after principal
photography rap because they wanted to
add a slightly more hopeful ending to
the movie this would later go on to get
echoed an attack of the Clones where we
close out with Anakin and Padme Anakin
has a mechanical hand and balthion Pad
may look out of the lake in his similar
position to look and layer either way it
closes out the movie ending what an
incredible film impressive
it's hard to overstate how much of a hit
it was and even back in 1980 it grossed
about 400 million at the box office
adjusted for inflation this is the
equivalent to about 1.9 billion which
would make it one of the most successful
movies of all time unfortunately Lucas
still had a bit of a rough time behind
the scenes and when making the film
there were constant spiraling costs the
bank threatened to pull along we talked
about before and Lucas was then left in
a position where he had to again
approach 20th Century Fox they agreed to
secure the loan but wanted a bigger cut
and Lucas managed to do it without
losing the sequel and Merchandising
rights however it still stuck as so
point for him and because of this he
took Riders over the Paramount this
easily ended up with 20th century
possibly losing out on more in the long
run and yeah whether it was a good deal
for them and Aura remains to be seen now
Luke is still well they're all owned by
Disney now anyway and Lucas still
benefited off this film massively though
and it's difficult to deny how much it
changed Cinema even as a kid I remember
this being a movie that really changed
my perspective on stuff because to me
yeah the good guys they were always
meant to win this flip the script and
dealt a devastating blow that a lot of
franchises still try to mimic today
still though I feel the original is the
best and this is a masterpiece in movie
making from start to finish this is a
film that took Star Wars from being a
franchise with a fun film into a
behemoth that altered how we look at
movies Arnie from the now playing
podcast said a line that's always stuck
with me and I think that it perfectly
sums this movie up when describing
Empire he said this is the film that
took Star Wars from a movie and then
turned it into a religion this is
something uh it sums it up for me and
this was really the movie where I fell
in love with the whole thing I hope
you've enjoyed watching the video and
have fallen in love with this too and if
you want to support videos like this
then please click the join button for 99
Pence or 99 cents a month you can really
make a major difference to the channel
and help us continue working away on
longer content like this instead of just
having to jam out small videos really
makes a massive difference and we try to
release early videos for members
whenever we can so you will get some
bonuses so thank you for for signing up
to that now if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our Brighton Avenue Hub which will be
linked on screen right now we've also
covered 2001 A Space Odyssey so whatever
Direction you want the Galaxy to take
you we've got a video for you Starship
Troopers that's gonna be next and with
that out the way thank you for singing
through this I've been Paul I'll see you
next time take care peace
thank you